Hello Freak bitches in some
something that's like a,
I,
I came in here and remember I got,
had gotten sick and I
had to postpone on you.
Um,
and anyways I went to
a hospital down in uh,
or up in Valencia I think,
and they had thrown me in a room for
three hours and they were thinking about
getting Hazmat suits out and all this
stuff because I thought you might've had
ebola because you came back from Africa,
right?
Yeah,
right,
right after the Ebola crisis,
but it had been,
um,
I had been back for like two months or
something or maybe even close to three
and a.
yeah,
they were going all crazy and stuff.
And this is just a stat that I
like to sum that grips my heart.
So that's why I want to say it now.
But,
um,
men,
I think I looked it up
right before I got in,
in here and it was around 11,000
people that have bullet took,
took out 11,000 people.
That's a ton.
It's a ton.
It's a brutal crisis.
But I just remember the uproar that,
that in the fear,
like the,
the outcry that happened publicly all
over the United States and only a couple
people got it here and then,
and still,
that's terrible.
Um,
but whenever I compare that 11,000 people
total in this ebola crisis and then
the stat for children,
and this is on water for
his website and stuff and,
and on ours and dude,
it's what I want to fight and let people
know because there should be a real
public outcry and uproar that 5,000 kids,
50,000 kids under the
age of five years old,
die every single day,
every single day because of dirty water,
because of waterborne disease,
because of waterborne illness.
That's a legit stat from UNICEF
or one of those like legit places,
five down,
$5,000 a day.
It's like,
it fluctuates from like 4,700
or something to $50,000 a day.
And like for me,
man,
I've,
I've held two of those children.
You know,
I've,
I've dug the grave,
I've had blisters on my hands.
I've had a little dude named Andy
Bo's blood on my hands and like,
like Bro,
it's,
it wrecks me and like that's why I'm
so passionate about this thing and like
I had come back and like I get it,
a bowl is terrible and we need to knock
it out because it can take out so many
people,
but why?
Why are people not like,
why don't they have their eyes open?
Their ears open their heart
open to hearing about 5,000
kids dying every day up
until the funeral of five other kids.
I've seen the grave of nine
or 10 others besides that,
like it.
These are just some of the
pygmies I've been to the.
I've seen the funerals going on with the,
of their oppressors,
like the slave masters and the Mokpala
than non pygmies that surround them.
Their kids are dying of
dirty water and it's not.
I don't,
I don't mean to go crazy,
but no,
it's not crazy at all.
It's that,
that statistic is crazy.
Five thousand a day a day and
they're under five years old.
So I mean,
I don't know how many with the six,
seven,
eight and nine year olds,
you know,
I've been to the funerals of those
kids where we are very strange,
but what we have,
what we focus our attention
on and the Ebola things,
just something that was over here because
we were worried about it coming over
here and we don't have
a problem over here.
We were,
it's so convenient for people to not look
at impoverished third world countries,
people that are just,
they've always been in this
sort of state of poverty.
So we just sort of accept
them as being like that.
We don't think that they necessarily,
that they have to live the way we
live or have access to clean water and
medical,
which is telling me,
think about it.
We worry about cecil the lion,
you know,
this the fuck comes out about cecil the
lion where everybody's going nuts and
freaking out.
Yeah,
I mean look,
poaching is terrible.
It's awful.
So the animals are beautiful and you know,
I get it.
But the way we really reacted to that,
to know your statistic,
to know that what you just said had 5,000
little kids die every day from dirty
water and people aren't
freaking out about that.
I think it's like every 20 seconds.
Who Attacks Pokemon people?
They're like the most adorable,
nicest people in the world.
But you look at that.
You said rural.
Do you not like the word world?
Like world?
Is that how you say world?
How do you say it?
W O r a l d o w e r before the.
Oh,
it rolls off the tongue easier
than going world world world.
World War old.
How do you say it?
World?
No,
you don't say it like that world.
How do you say world now?
That's the right way.
That's why they say no.
You say rural of.
How does he say at Jamie?
You say Debbie,
I can't even.
It's the best thing in the
world world.
Okay.
Keep saying it like that.
We're good.
No,
that's when I say
world world war now.
He doesn't even say world world.
World War old.
That's what he say.
Rural called road.
The best thing in the world,
the,
the theory being the star wars program
has apparently never really effective and
the scientists that were
behind the star wars program,
a fuck load of them died by suicide,
by murder,
and there's a giant list of them
and it's one of the most fascinating
conspiracies and modern time find it.
Okay.
Um,
these guys that knew the people
that knew the scientists,
the engineers dead,
like almost all of them,
they all died like murdered suicide.
And like very,
very suspicious that
someone did like a number,
like,
you know,
they did like a percentage.
Like what are the odds that all these
people were murdered inside of billion to
one?
Yeah.
Well,
they knew.
They all knew that it was bullshit.
The Star Wars program,
they'd spend millions,
untold billions of dollars to develop
this completely ineffective system to
shoot missiles at a sky was
never proven to work ever.
And those scientists are all dead as food.
Here it goes,
dead scientists.
And look at us,
there's the list mark
coney scientists mystery,
the 19 eighties over two dozen science
graduates and experts working on the
Marconi or plessy.
How do you say that?
Plessy pl plus sss,
why defense systems died in
mysterious circumstances,
most appearing to be suicides.
The Mod denied.
These scientists had been involved in the
classified star wars projects and that
the desks were in any way connected.
But look at how these guys died.
Look at this guy,
computer programmer.
I'm Keith Bowden.
Scientists in Essex University
engaged in work for Marconi.
Bubba Bubba,
circumstance of death fatal car crash.
His vehicle went off out of control across
a dual carriageway and plunged into a
disused railway lines.
We didn't even drinking
with family and friends.
Denied the allegations.
So what the fuck was it where?
Where's the autopsy?
Coroner report an accident.
Here's another one.
Lieutenant Colonel Anthony.
Godly expertise,
head of work study unit at the
Royal College of Military Science.
Circumstance of death disappeared
mysteriously without explanation.
Presumed that that's fucking expertise.
Radar designer and draftsman draftsman,
I guess as draftsman
Troutman with Marconi,
circumstance of death,
death by shotgun,
blast at home corners,
verdict suicide,
Jonathan Walz,
29 expertise digital communications expert
who had worked at GDC and had British
Telecom,
secret research center at the Blah,
blah,
blah.
Here's is danger.
Exactly died as a result of falling from
a hotel room in west Africa working for
British Telecom.
He had expressed fears that
his life was in danger,
corners,
verdict,
open,
and he just goes on and on and on.
Look out.
You see how?
See scrolling Luchow's as Jamie's growing.
Look at the upper right hand corner.
Look how fucking long this list is like.
Scroll down to the bottom of this list
so you can see how many people were on
this.
Oh my God.
Look at this.
This is all a lot of people that were
attached to the star wars program.
All of them in the late
eighties and the early nineties.
Dead as fuck.